well
hello everyone good morning
welcome to day two of uh ndc london 2021
my name is this session is about
writing tests with c sharp
just to check that everybody is on the
same as on the same page
so i have lots of stuff to go through so
let's just jump right into it
um let me tell you just a little bit
about myself
uh let me see if i can actually change
this light yeah there you go
uh as i said my name is enrico i
am a freelance programmer this is me
freelancing from home i also do
a fair bit of training like
online courses workshops and
presentations like
like this one uh all that's
done from home no who would have thought
anyway we're not here to talk about that
we are here to talk about
writing tests using a library
called auto fixture now if you've
never heard about auto fixture let me
just give you a quick intro
auto fixture is a an open source library
uh 4.net
whose goal is to help you
write a better test by
auto generating test data for you now
what that means we are going to get into
in a moment
but just to give you an overview out of
which has been around
for uh i would say around 10 years now
and it has been used quite a bit i would
say
it has seen some some amount of of
usage and in the interest of full
disclosure i
am a contributor to um to the project
and i've been for a few years
and yeah so uh
this presentation is about how to use
auto fixture to when you do tdd
to write dry tests now
let's start with a premise and the
premise is
that tests that are small in size
and that are expressive in the sense
that
they actually tell you what it is they
are trying to test
that's a good thing we want that in our
tests
do we all agree on that premise
i'm gonna take that as a yes yes
good perfect
uh how we're gonna do that well we're
going to leverage
three unit testing patterns and these
are well documented patterns
that are part of the book x unit
patterns
that have been around for you know many
years we're going to use
three of these patterns
and but we're not going to implement
them ourselves we are going to use a
library
that implements those pattern for us and
leverage it that way and if you can
guess that library is out to feature
let's talk about this this word right
here actually
as let's focus on everybody agrees on
what
auto means that's automatic but what is
a
fixture so let's focus a bit on this
let's talk about what a fixture is
because it's kind of important
in this context now when you write a
test
you have a system that you're trying to
test and in the case of unit tests that
would be that would be a class now in
order to test a system
you have to put it into some kind of
context
well that context in which you put your
system under test
in order to verify its behavior that's
the fixture
and how does a fixture look like well
you have if you've written
at least one unit test in your life you
know what uh
how a fixture looks like you invoke
methods
or set properties on your system on the
test
you generate values that you pass into
the methods
as as test arguments
and ideally a test
should contain a pretty small amount
of this context because ideally in a
unit test you should verify
one thing and you know in a perfect
world
that one thing will require a minimal
amount
of context however reality is much
different than that
we all know that these contexts they
grow in size
and you just don't need just maybe for
your particular scenario you need one
value
but because of the nature of the system
you have to create a lot more stuff
in order to be able to test it at all
and that involves creating
entire object graphs coming up with more
values
sometimes you don't know what to pass in
so you pass null
and that's how our tests usually look
like a lot of
setup code for what is actually very
little behavior to verify
but we have another problem is so
it's not just it's like it's it's not
enough to have big fixture
one other problem is that for everything
every time you
invoke your system on the test by
passing arguments
or by actually invoking its api
you are creating coupling onto it
and that we know that uh coupling what
it means is that it's gonna be harder to
change
now imagine
not having one test with this scenario
but having the same thing be repeated
for
every test of course every test is going
to need a fixture
and in most of the cases
if it's the same system you are testing
you're gonna have to create
pretty much the same amount of content
context for every test
so we have duplicated setup code
everywhere maybe sometime you change
something
in particular test for example you
change this value to full
or maybe you pass 40 42 instead of
of 12 and what happens is
it starts small but it grows really big
and you know that's not good
so
how can how are we going to solve that
problem
well let's take a look at how a test is
built
you all know that that setup that we've
been talking about
in the formal terminology that's called
the arrange phase and that's where we
set up our fixture
now that's usually pretty big the second
part of the test
is act the third part is assert
now you see the proportions here a range
is a lot bigger than the other two
now what we want to do without the
fixture is reduce the size of this
range so that it contains the minimal
amount
of context that we need for a particular
scenario
so in other words if the scenario
ideally
would require a certain size of context
we want the fixture to match that size
we don't want to create
anything more than than what is
necessary
in other words we want to reduce
the amount of calls that we make onto
our system on the test
does reducing coupling and the
duplication
because you know that fewer explicit
calls you make to onto your system on
the test
the easier is going to be to change
so let's switch gear and talk about
these three unit testing patterns now
that we have talked about what the
problem is
let's talk about how we're going to
attack it
the first unit test testing pattern that
we're going to use
is called anonymous data now what's
anonymous data
well it's any input value
that exercises the code path under test
now let's let's unpack it
imagine a a method like this it takes an
input value that's an integer
and it has exactly one line of code that
checks whether the value is positive or
not
now it doesn't really matter what number
you pass in
into this function that line is always
going to be run so
you say that that value can be anonymous
as long as it exercises that line it
doesn't really matter
if that's a 2 or a so we can leave it
anonymous
the second unit test pattern
is called equivalent sets and now this
is sounding
more exotic by the minute so what is it
given that we have anonymous values that
we can pass in
the set of those values
that exercises the same code path
through the code is said to be an
equivalent set
now again let's take an example
imagine a slightly more complex function
where you have an input value and you
have two branches that
execute based on what that value is
now if i invoke this method with the
values 4 and 9
those values are bigger than 3
and they will execute that line of code
if i invoke this method with 0 and 2
those values are less than 3 that means
they will execute
the other branch now 4
and 9 and 0 and 2 those
are equivalent sets those from the point
of view of the test
it doesn't really matter if it's one or
the other as long as it exercises the
same line of code so those are
equivalent
the third and final unit testing pattern
is called the taste data builder
that actually no pun intended builds
upon the other two
now as if you remember what we just said
we said that
uh we can leave some values
anonymous when we write tests as long as
they exercise
the code that we are interested in
verifying so if we can leave them
anonymous
it means that we can actually
delegate the responsibility of coming up
with those values
to an external party and that external
party is the
test data builder so a test data builder
is a factory
we all love factories that create
values used to test a specific
code path
so given this method any small
positive number that we pass in is
going to be enough to exercise all the
possible code path
this means that our test data builder
the values that we it will come up with
are enough to cover the vast majority of
the code path that we have in our code
bases
so the usual 80 20 rule says
that a test data builder in can cover
80 percent of the cases just with its
default values that it comes
up with for example a string is going to
be a string and it's just going to be a
small positive integer
a boolean can be either true or false so
given these defaults we can cover
80 of the of the code paths however
there is a remaining 20
in which we actually need the value to
be of a specific kind
and for those cases
our test data builder will need to have
some way
to let us customize the test data that
it produces
how let's let's now that we have been
gone through the theory
let's talk about how we're going to
demonstrate
now in this talk i'm going to implement
a conway's game of life uh within
c-sharp
in a test driven manner using
how to fixture as our test data builder
now if you are familiar with the
conway's game of life that's good if
you're not here is a quick
intro game of life is a
logic game invented by conway
that consists of a grid of cells and
each cell
can have either one of two states it can
either be alive
or it can be that now
this entire grid of cells
is going to be refreshed and that means
that you basically recalculate the value
for all those cells
based on four ex specific rules
and all those four rules have to do with
the state of a any given cell's
neighbors
now as you refresh this grid that's
called a generation
any particular snapshot of cells is a
generation so
when you calculate a new generation
based on those rules
some cells will come alive some other
cells will be dead
and that creates patterns for every time
you refresh this grid
and that's kind of interesting because
based on what the start pattern is
every time you you refresh so
some patterns are perpetual they're they
will go on forever other patterns will
eventually lead to all the cells being
dead
all based on what the star pattern is
pretty interesting stuff
now we are now going to implement all
four of these rules otherwise we'll be
here until tomorrow
we're going to implement just one of the
four rules
and this rule is called the rule of
under population
which goes like this
a cell that's alive
but that has fewer than two live
neighbors
is going to die in the next generation
due to underpopulation
so that's the rule we're going to
implement we're going to implement it in
c sharp
uh in a test driven manner
so without further ado let's tdd
okay let's see if i can
there you go switch to visual studio
code
all right so what i have here is um yeah
with the studio code
i have a sample project on my
left which might be your right i'm not
really sure
anyway on one side are the tests that
we're going to write
and on the opposite side we have the
production code
so i have a little starting point here
where i have created
a test class now notice how i'm writing
this test class
usually maybe if you're used to having
your tests
in a class that has the same name as the
class you're testing
plus the test or test
suffix i also
used to do that but a few years ago i
stumbled upon a different style of
writing unit test
that's called bdd style testing
and where bdd is behavior driven
development now bdd style
testing means that instead of focusing
on the implementation
you are rather focusing on the behavior
that you are implementing
and that all starts with naming your
tests so
instead of having a test class for every
production code
class i have a test class for each
scenario and in this case the scenario
is
when i calculate a new generation
this is what i want to test which is
basically as we just said the essence of
the game of life it's refreshing this
grid
of cells it's producing new generations
and that really helps me focus on the
functionality
now we said we're going to do it test
driven
so here we are with a blank sheet and we
have to write the first test
now we all know that's the most the
hardest part of writing tdd
what uh what really helps is to think
of what is the simplest
most trivial piece of functionality that
my code has to accomplish
now in this case we have a grid of cells
so if i pass in
into my generation
class if i pass in a grid of cells into
that
and i ask it to calculate a new grid
i expect to get back a new grid
so a first test could be something along
the lines of
when calculating
when calculating a new generation it
should return
a generation containing cells
that's the easiest thing i can come up
with
when it if i were to implement
a game of life algorithm
now we mentioned the beginning of this
talk that every test has three
sections the arrange phase the act and
the assert now let's
start by writing this test without a
picture without using those
unit test patterns let's write it the
usual way
and after we are done let's take a look
and let's see how we can
refactor the tests to become drier
and to become smaller and more
expressive
so let's start by writing it a regular
way
the arranged phase could
look something like that
we have a generation class
which contains a
list of cells and
these cells they have coordinates
in the x and y along the x and y axis
now as you uh and by the way
our system on the test which i called
sut
system on the test it consists of
a grid which whose responsibility
is to calculate a new generation of
cells
now if you notice here
it doesn't really matter what these
values are
for the purpose of our test they could
they could be anything they're not
even neighbors we haven't really
specified the size of the grid either
we're just passing some random numbers
because from the point of view of this
test
we are just interested in getting back a
generation of cells it doesn't really
matter what their coordinates are
so these values are anonymous just a
hint for later
so this being tdd of course we have a
compilation error because
none of these classes that we have
mentioned actually exist yet
so let's go ahead and implement those
so let's start with a class called a
generation
and which is going to have a constructor
which accepts
a list of cell objects
so let me just quickly implement that
so as you see here i just have a
generation that takes an
innumerable of cell
and of course the cell class doesn't
exist either
so let's go ahead and implement that
cell
let's see public actually i like it to
be indented class
cell
and the cell class is going to have a
constructor which accepts two
core two numbers which are the
coordinate
and let's put two properties for good
measure
so far so good pretty simple stuff
now the other the third thing we need to
create is the actual
grid which is our system on the test so
let's put it where i'm putting all the
classes in the same file of course
you're not going to do that in
production code well actually when doing
tdd it's pretty convenient
to have all the code in the same file to
begin with
just because you it gives you less
friction and then
when you have made the test pass
you know the famous red green refactor
first make the test fail
then make it pass and then refactor in
the refactor phase
that's where you can move out the
classes to different files
so public class let's call it grid
and which should be
good so let's try to compile
now i'm using visual studio code with
omnisharp
to give me the intellisense so yeah the
compilation has succeeded
however the squiggly lines are still
here
and that's because omnisharp has hasn't
really caught up yet
but it will eventually so let's proceed
uh the second part of the test is going
to be the act that's when we
actually invoke our refresh method
and here we go so we are invoking a
method called
refresh on our
system on the test where we're passing
the the generation that we have created
and we expect to get back a
new generation where hopefully
the cell the cells are still the same
of course the refresh method doesn't
exist so let's go ahead and
implement it
and so remember that when when you're
doing tdd
you have to write the least amount of
code possible
to make the test pass and in this case
i'm just going to create a stub
of a refresh method that takes a
generation and
returns a different generation but in
this case i'm just going to return now
because our goal is to just have this
compile
so let's go ahead and do that
perfect compiling is the first
green in the red green refactor cycle
the third phase is the assert so let's
verify
that what was what did our test say it
should return a generation containing
cells okay so we just need to verify
that this generation is not
empty so
here is how we express it we say that
the next generation
should not be empty now if this looks
new to you
this is another library that i really
like called fluent assertions
so instead of writing assert that or
assert
not empty like like the assertion
libraries built into x unit or n unit
do i use a third party library that's
just dedicated to
giving me assertion methods and those
are
social methods are implemented as
extension methods
which means i can append them instead of
having them up front
what this allows me to do is i can
express this
as a sentence thus making it more
expressive however in this case we see
that
this is not compiling because the not be
empty extension method
extends innumerable so in this case
we are assuming that the next generation
or rather the generation class is
in of itself and a list of cells and
innumerable of cells
which is is actually what it is so it's
not a bad idea
to in this case go ahead and implement
innumerable of cell
on degeneration itself because if you
think about it a generation
is a list of cells
so the implementation is also rather
trivial
so let's just go ahead and implement
the enumerate get enumerator methods
where you just
iterate through the list of cells that's
in
in degeneration
now let's go ahead and compile let's see
if this
is happy now yeah looks good
now let's finally run the test after all
this
okay so the test failed and not only the
test
but my microphone also failed in the
to together with the test so that was
kind of catastrophic
let's say that that's hopefully it
doesn't happen next time around my tests
otherwise it's going to be really spooky
um
so not only does it have to fail but it
also has to fail
in the expected way in the expected way
is
we expected the next generation not to
be empty
but we found no so that's exactly what
we wanted
so now the next step is implement the
least amount of code
that we that we can write to make this
test pass
now what is the least amount of code we
can write
now of course we just want
the test just asks for a generation
a list of cells so let's give it an
array
containing one
cell and that cell doesn't really
it doesn't even have to have
[Music]
any actual cells in it
because let's see it's generational so
yeah you know it's
really sharp at the omni shop that's
going crazy let's
try to compile and see what happens
to demo generation why not it is an
innumerable of cell
isn't it
new uh of course yeah we pass it a new
generation
generation where we pass a an array of
cells that contains just one item and
that i that cell doesn't really have to
actually be an actual cell
so let's compile
perfect let's run the test
let's see if it's still passing perfect
now we have the green
so red we did that green we have now
refactoring we'll do later let's proceed
to the next test
next test is now that we know that our
method actually returns a generation
with some cells
now we need to verify that if we send in
a certain amount of cells what we want
to get back is the same amount
so the test here now becomes the next
step is
it should return the same number of
cells
in other words this refresh method
shouldn't
add nor remove any cells
there you go so how is the arranged
phase going to be
in this case well as i told you before
when you are testing the same scenario
um with different assertions we are
going to be creating the same arrange
so these arranged phases are going to
look a lot alike
they're going to be duplicated so in
this case we're
still going to have to create a
generation we're still going to need to
pass a list of cells
in this case let's just pass three
instead of two just to make some
no something new again the numbers of
the coordinates don't really matter
the act of course is also going to be
the same
we send in this generation we refresh it
we get back a new generation
and this time the assert is going to be
different
because next now we are going to verify
that if i pass in
three cells i want to get back exactly
three cells all good
let's run this test and see what happens
failed perfect microphone is still on
also good
how does it fail let's take a look we
expected the next generation to contain
three items
but we found one which is exactly what
our implementation is doing
so again let's make this test pass now
what is the least amount of code i can
write to make the test pass
well of course i could write
three here or four
but then we wouldn't be moving the
implementation forward so
another trick with tdd is that of course
you are playing devil's advocate all the
time by saying what is the least amount
of code i can write
but you can't just stand still on the
same place you need to actually drive
the implementation forward so
in this case just changing that number
wouldn't get us anywhere
what we need to do instead is go from
a constant value like in this case
to a variable so what can we return
well the simplest thing we can do is
that we return the exact same
generation that we're getting so we went
from hard coding
an array with one item to
which is a constant to a variable
this should be the least amount of code
that we can write to make this test pass
and the other one of course
and indeed we have now two passing tests
now the third and final the rule of
three
threat test that we have to write is the
actual underpopulation rule so now we're
just being
setting up the basic infrastructure to
have a grid of cells
now let's actually implement this under
population rule
if you remember the rule says
that if there is an alive cell
that has fewer than
two or it doesn't have any neighbors
that are also alive
it's going to die in the next generation
due to underpopulation
so in this case the arrange is going to
be
slightly different than we have because
in this case
we actually do care about the number of
cells
and the state of those cells
so let's see how this arrange looks like
so instead of just creating a bunch of
cells
in this case we create just one cell
which is the one that we want to die
from one generation to the other
and that let's call it the solitary cell
because it doesn't have
any neighbors another another new piece
of
information that we need to bake in is
the state of the cell so now the
coordinates still don't matter
but in this case we actually want the
cell to have a state which is either
alive or dead so it's a boolean
and we want it to be alive to begin with
then we're passing the usual
list of cells to the generation in this
case we pass
in just that one we create our grid
which is our system on the test and the
rest you know the drill
so
in this case we actually don't care
about
the um the value of that we get back
instead let's just verify
let's see let's just verify that
this cell that we have passed in
its alive property should be false
so we are just passing in a cell with a
certain state with a certain with no
neighbors
we pass it in we say refresh and then we
check that that cell
now is dead
of course this doesn't compile because
we have introduced a new constructor
parameter
so let's go ahead and add that to the
cell class
which is over here so let's do add a
live
let's also add a property
now we do it as a readable and writable
property because
you can't change the coordinates of a
cell but you can change its state
i know maybe it shouldn't have be done
through a property but you know for the
sake of this exercise
let's make this a mutable state
and let's assign it from the constructor
okay now let's see if you're good
what do you think happens now
oh compilation error why
i can almost hear you say that hey you
just added a new constructor parameter
but all your existing tests are passing
just two arguments so now we have just
broken
our existing tests and this is a
a very you know concrete proof
of the coupling that i was talking about
earlier
for every call you make to your system
on the test
in every single one of these arranged
phases you are creating couple your
tests are coupling
themselves to your implementation which
inhibits your ability to evolve it and
to refactor it
so in this case we we need to move this
implementation forward
or we just broke our existing tests now
in this case there are only two of them
but imagine having a library of hundreds
if not thousands of tests
and by making a change in your api
you're suddenly breaking all of them and
who wants to go through
thousands of tests and fix them so what
happens in most cases
you just don't refactor your tests are
now
a burden i know it sounds
really really dark but in this case we
can actually get out of it
by leveraging a feature in this shop
language called default parameters
where you can say that okay i'm just
going to assume that
when i create a new cell if i don't pass
any state
that cell is going to be dead
and just by doing this move i now have
a fix my compilation errors but you see
that this is a
a lucky situation you're not always
you're not always able to do this
so now the test starts compiling again
and let's run the test we need to see it
fail
yeah two past one failed why is it
failing
we expected the solitary cell dot alive
to be false
but we got it true in other in other
words it hasn't changed its state
perfect
now what is the least amount of code i
can write to make this test pass
now the code i'm about to write is the
most naive trivial implementation which
is of course
not what the final implementation should
look like but in our case we're not
interested in producing the perfect
implementation of the game of life
we are focusing on the tests so let's do
the
most naive embarrassing implementation
ever
and say that given the seed the
generation that i pass in
i'm gonna get the first element out of
it
and i'm gonna set the alive property to
false how is that
i can almost hear the screams of the
people what are you doing
i know i know but this is not of course
you're gonna
you know ideally you write more tests
you evolve the implementation you
refactor this away
but we're gonna stop here for now
let's just forget about that that
implementation
perfect all three tests by passing now
we are in a state
where we can forget about this
implementation for now
and just look at our tests now you see
the problem i already talked about some
of the problems that i mentioned in the
beginning
we have some we have duplication
we have coupling and we have also
interesting things like what are these
numbers
are they meaningful what happens if i
change one of them so there are lots of
these questions
so um how can we solve the problem we
can solve it by leveraging
a taste data builder like autofeature
now let's start refactoring those tests
and now i can almost hear you
asking hey but if you refactor your
tests
how do you know that you haven't broken
anything well
let me tell you this
when you have tests and you're in
production code you can only ever
refactor one or the other never both at
the same time
so in this case i'm not touching the
implementation the implementation stays
the same
we are refactoring the tests
so by not touching implementation we
know that we haven't broken
any tests so
let's change this arrange and let's use
a test data builder like how to feature
so auto feature
starts with an object called a fixture
like like of course it says it right on
the name
a fixture class
and the feature class has a method
called create which you can use to
actually ask it to produce a value for
us so in our case we're going to say
fixture
dot create what type do you want to
create you i want to create a generation
and i can also ask it to create my
system on the test so let's create a
grid
so let's remove this
so now instead of manually creating
invoking all the constructor and passing
coming up with the values myself i just
delegated all of that to the test data
builder and ask it just
just give me an instance of this with
good default values
let's see if it still passes the test
yeah it does perfect
now in this case
we said that what happens if i change
this number to a different one
for example what happens if i add
another cell
and pass in some random values of course
if i change this value to 4
that should still
oh i forgot a comma there
the test should still pass because it
doesn't really matter how many
there are as long as that's the same
number that's coming out
so let's use autofixture to create all
of this setup for us
we're basically doing the same thing
um
there you go so create a fixture we ask
you to create a generation and
we ask you to create a grid just like we
did before let's get rid of this stuff
and let's see if the test is still
passing
what do you think
no test has failed let's see why
i mean it shouldn't right so expected
the next generation to contain four
items
yeah we said four but we got three so
what is this
remember auto fixture works by using
reflection so
what it does is that when i ask you to
create a generation
it's going to look at its constructor
and see that aha the generation
requires an immune numerable of cell
and of course the cell object is going
to have
x and y and the alive property so those
who are going to get
just some random positive numbers but
when auto feature is tasked with
creating a list of anything
if you are not specific and tell how
many items the list should have
it's going to give you three why three
because it's a
good same default so in this case
we get three not four
because out of each other is using its
default
but if you look if you look at our test
does it really doesn't really matter for
the test how many there are
no it doesn't as long as they are the
same number
so instead of hard coding the value
we can say have the same count as
the seed
so by using a test data builder in this
case
we have made our test less
hard coded more generic
and in that way also more expressive
because now it doesn't really matter how
many there are we're just checking that
they have the same amount
so does this test pass
yes it does now the final test
is a little bit more complicated because
now we actually do care
about the number of cells and we also
care about the state
so how can we write this now remember
the 80 20 rule
up until now we just leveraged the the
default
values that autofeature comes up with so
they cover
80 of the cases in this case we're going
to use
the customization api that that tauto
feature has
in order to actually go in and tell it
okay i wanted to create
exactly one cell and that cell needs to
be alone and it needs to be alive
so we start by using the fixture as
always
however now we need to tell out the
feature how it should create certain
types of
objects so we say customize
customize what type well we want to
customize the
cell type
and this method takes a lambda
where you say create and then you say
with
and then you need to specify okay which
property do you want to set to a
particular value
well i want to set the alive property
what value do you want to give it i want
to give it true
so now i'm telling how to feature
customize for every time you want for
this particular test the fixture is
always
for one test only for this particular
test when autofeature has to create a
cell
it's going to create it with the alive
property set to true
now the second part of the customization
is we want the list of
cells to contain just one item not three
not four not any number other than one
so it's another customization we need to
use
customize single
let's go what is it called single
actually i don't remember the name let
me see
single element sequence there you go
so fixture
customize new single
element sequence of cell
i'm just gonna explain it real quick
what is this so this is a customization
that's pre-packaged
and what this says it tells out a
picture that every time you have
to create a sequence of cells that means
an innumerable
of cells it's going to give it
a single element
so now that we have customized
auto-picture and
told it what to do for those types then
we can just create
our generation and our grid as usual
so let's get rid of that
now we have another problem you see now
we don't
we no longer have access to the solitary
cell variable because it's being created
behind the curtains by auto fixture as
part of the arrange phase
we don't actually have an a a reference
to that value
but that's also something that we can
easily solve because
if we instead
check the return value of our method the
next generation
then we can say next generation
dot single and in this case we do know
for a fact that the next generation
is going to contain a single element
because we told autofixture to do it
so it's perfectly fine to go ahead
and build on those assumptions because
those are part of the arranged phase
so we say that the the single cell in
the next generation should be
alive should be false let's see if this
passes
perfect so now we have refactored the
tests
they are not only more expressive they
are smaller
but they are also decoupled from the
implementation
what does this mean it means that if i
want to go into the implementation
and improve it somehow for example
i no longer need this
and what about this constructor what if
instead of having an innumerable of cell
i want to allow the caller to specify
any number of cell objects by using
params
so for example i can say params sell
cells like that no making it more
flexible
now i can make those changes and i can
still run my tests
and verify that i haven't broken
anything
so this is a really powerful those three
patterns
and a a auto feature as an
implementation of three unit testing
patterns
gives us the freedom to write
tests that are readable expressive and
that are decoupled from our
implementation
the only of course we're going to have
be coupled
at least a certain amount because we
need to actually invoke our system on
the test
but we are free to refactor our code
and take advantage of the safety net
that are our tests
pretty powerful stuff so now
i have a few minutes so let me go back
to the slides just to wrap this up
now if i gonna remember just one thing
from this presentation let's make it
three things
the first one is do not hardcode
values into your test because they
confuse the picture they are they create
questions
that are not really relevant the test
should be readable as is and they should
communicate what it is that they're
trying to verify
the second takeaway is
try to minimize the amount of coupling
that you
that your tests have on your system on
the test
because that will give you the freedom
to refactor
and having the freedom to refactor means
easier maintenance of your code base
which is the ultimate
goal that we strive for every day as
programmers
with that i just want to give you a few
pointers
so there is a an auto fixture tag on
stack overflow where the
myself and a few others from the
autofeatures
team are watching and trying to ask for
questions
as they come up and how to feature
itself of course is open source and it's
on github so if you have any issues or
questions you can post them over there
as for myself if you liked what you've
seen today
i just wanted to give you a pointer to
my pre-assigned courses
i have a few plural asset courses out my
latest one is about github actions
and there is the link if you want to
check those out
i really appreciate that and with that
i want to say thank you for watching
this presentation
and i'll stick around the chat for at
least the rest of today
so if you want to ping me there and ask
me questions i'll be very happy to
answer
if i can and yeah
enjoy the rest of your conference thank
you